BLM activist John Earl Sullivan has been
convicted for his role in incitement on
January 6th that is right this is a BLM
far-left activist and the funny thing
about it is we all know the media has uh
has in the past reported on his
activities we know that he was a
frequent um attendee and organizer for
many leftist rallies we know that's on
video he's cheering for what's happening
at the capital and uh now we've got the
corporate press saying he's an
anti-establishment
activist right because now they're
trying to deflect from the fact that
he's a black lives matter supporter and
that was basically what it was all about
he even said in the uh there's video of
him from the from that day where he's
saying I don't I'll be on anybody's side
if they're going to tear it all down
yada Yad y so that's going to be uh uh
interesting how we see liberals and the
left respond to this considering well
for a long time a lot of conservatives
said there were anti there were leftists
there now it's one guy so we'll see